the movie is set in dystopian France
where the economic situation has become
a nightmare as only 20 percent of the
citizens are employed and have access to
resources because of this the remaining
population starts rioting but help never
arrives instead the government banishes
them indefinitely it has been 30 years
since that incident the unemployed
people now live in what's called The
Zone whereas the employed live in the
prosperous part of the town the two sets
of humans are divided by a large wall
which is guarded by impenetrable
security people in the zone suffer from
diseases hunger and they do not have
access to Safe Drinking Water while the
ones on the other side of the wall have
all the world's resources at their
disposal in the first scene we are
introduced to a man named Ruben Garcia
who lives in the town with his family
Reuben and his wife face work as
technicians in different parts of
aquaville the town's only water company
meanwhile his shrewd and selfish father
Silas Garcia is a top level executive in
the same company aquaville also supplies
water to the Zone but only once or twice
a month the this is certainly not enough
to satiate the demand so the zoners
often rely on drugs to kill their thirst
one day all the residents of the Zone
gather at the wall where the prime
minister of France Nadia passaron is set
to arrive for a historic visit as
everyone from the town is glued to their
televisions the PM's Convoy enters the
Zone it's then revealed that 13 months
ago a group of activists from The Zone
kidnapped PM Nadia's husband Moretti who
is also the minister of Labor in protest
of the wall and after months of
negotiation the two parties have finally
reached a deal to free the minister in
Her speech PM Nadia claims that she
hopes one day people of different social
classes can live together in peace she
then announces that as the first step
towards that goal the activists will
release Moretti and in exchange ten
thousand unemployed zoners will be
provided with jobs in the town under the
solidarity Job Program the announcement
stuns everyone inside and outside the
wall while the zoners are elated the
town residents are worried because they
haven't interacted with the unemployed
people for more than 30 years moreover
most people in town hold negative views
about them because of hateful propaganda
soon Minister Moretti is released and he
returns home with his wife it is then
revealed that PM Nadia dislikes the
zoners as much as the average Town
resident and she only agreed to the deal
because her husband's kidnapping caused
an international stir the World Bank
also started threatening her government
with sanctions if she continued to
ignore the demands of the zoners
meanwhile at the wall the zoner's
randomly selected for the program are
called for an interview among them is a
single mother izia and her friend larcom
the interview is pretty intense and
people who are involved in drugs
trafficking and gambling are swiftly
rejected at the same time Izzy is only
child Noah is at a school where his
class teacher Robinson is criticizing
the current French system he explains
that one shouldn't have to work in order
to exist with dignity in society Noah
opposes and says that work is a
liberating he gives an example of his
father who won a lottery 13 years ago
and used the prize money to move to
South Europe where he is happy living
now what does that have to do with work
being liberating the movie then cuts to
aquaville where Ruben learns that his
department head has worked himself to
death however instead of being sad
Reuben is elated as he has been waiting
to take over his boss's position without
wasting any time he then messages his
well-connected father Silas at the prime
minister's residence Moretti gets
medical treatment and it becomes clear
that he had been tortured for Intel
later PM Nadia's head of security
Colonel Jean interviews Moretti and the
latter assures her that he hasn't
divulged any state secrets to the
radicals as a result Nadia immediately
declares that moretius fit to work and
again makes him the minister of labor at
aquaville we learned that Reuben's wife
thias is having an affair with one of
her colleagues Hans the two are actually
conspiring to steal important business
data from aquavel which they plan to
sell in exchange for money and use it to
move abroad and start a new life see
what complacency does to people however
their attempts have failed so far thias
hasn't been able to get anywhere close
to her father-in-law silas's office to
make matters worse the authorities have
started suspecting that Hans is involved
in something illegal and he is being
investigated later Reuben tells face
about his intentions to apply for his
light boss's position he desperately
wants the promotion so he can afford to
send their autistic daughter mael to
Phoenix Academy a popular school for
specially abled children this is because
if male keeps studying in normal schools
she won't get any jobs in the future and
thus will end up in the zone however the
Arrogant face is confident that Reuben's
selfish father won't help him secure the
promotion she also adds that they should
have gotten rid of mail a long time ago
unfortunately the little girl overhears
the conversation and becomes sad so
Reuben goes over to comfort her the next
day Reuben nervously approaches his
father Silas and requests help to secure
the management position surprisingly the
latter agrees and he even invites Reuben
to an exclusive ministerial party the
next day meanwhile at aquaville Hans
meets with pm Nadia's head of security
Gene Mars it turns out both of them are
secret Zone sympathizers and they are
colluding with the activists to find
dirt on aquaville which is the biggest
Financial supporter of PM Nadia's
government face is set to steal
information from silas's Office the next
day and flee The Zone elsewhere izia and
her friend larcom clear the interviews
and become excited as they are finally
getting employed now don't get too
excited work sucks the next day hundreds
of zoners are transported to the town
for their first day of work izia is
assigned to work at Reuben's house and
the latter is stunned to learn that she
looks exactly like his wife meanwhile PM
Nadia and her team hand-pick larkham and
make him praise the solidarity program
on TV in the next scene face is
apprehended and taken in for questioning
by aquaville security her only offense
is that she is frequently hanging out
with Hans a suspected Zone collaborator
Reuben who is getting late for the party
tries to contact her but without success
hence with no options left he convinces
izia to accompany him to the party as
his
later the two reached the venue and are
pretty nervous with all the dignitaries
around however with some help from his
father Reuben and his supposed wife
managed to impress the CEO of aquaville
meanwhile after being freed to go face
goes straight to Jean and tells her that
she couldn't complete the job upset Gene
takes this out and smuggles her into the
Zone where she is picked up by an
activist named Boris the same day Hans
is exposed so he too is transferred to
the Zone after face continues to be out
of contact Reuben again asks izia to
play his wife's role the next day izia
is scared of getting caught but Reuben
offers to pay her a hefty amount so she
reluctantly agrees with this he teaches
izia faces job and eventually sends her
to work later in the news it is reported
that 22 solidarity workers were attacked
by Town residents on just the first day
this worries PM Nadia as she must show
the world that reconciliation is
happening therefore she appoints larcom
as the special advisor to minister
Moretti so he can help make the
solidarity program a success larcom is
excited about his new role as he
genuinely wants the two sets of people
to get along but Moretti hates the
unemployed because of the torture he
endured during his captivity he
strangles larkham and warns him to keep
his distance on the other hand as izia
tries to adapt to her new job Reuben
goes to officially enter his name in the
race to become the director of water
quality meanwhile Noah finds a 13 year
old Magazine with a cover story on the
woman who won the lottery that year Noah
is shocked as he realizes that izzia
lied to him about his father winning the
lottery hurt he wanders around and meets
a local Thief Valley the two quickly
Bond and Valley invites him to her place
where they have narcotics elsewhere face
finally learns that Hans deceived her
and he is actually a Zone collaborator
she feels betrayed and threatens to
report him while investigating hanz's
spy activities the police narrow down
three female employees he came in
contact with one of the women is izia
AKA Thais Garcia the police present the
woman before head of security Gene Mars
Gene is shocked to see someone claiming
to be face Garcia as she personally sent
the real one to the Zone later she
follows stays home and learns that it is
actually Izzy opposing his face Garcia
Gene relays the information to the
activist from earlier Boris and asks him
to establish contact with izia in hopes
of using her to steal data from
aquaville when izia returns back to the
Zone she learns that Noah is missing and
starts looking for him everywhere
however she is approached by Boris lo
and behold he reveals that he is
actually Noah's estranged father Ethan
due to his involvement in the
anti-system movements Ethan abandoned
his family and changed his name to Boris
it turns out izia had to lie to her son
to protect his feelings Eason asks for
her help but hizia isn't pleased to see
him and declines to cooperate elsewhere
Noah almost overdoses on narcotics so a
scared Valley drops him at the local
teacher Robinson's home the latter
immediately contacts isia and the two
somehow revive the teenager after Noah
goes to bed izia confides in Robinson
that she is quitting her job and heading
south with her son on with whatever she
has saved however when she returns home
she is devastated to learn that Ethan
and his men broke into her room and
stole her savings hence left with no
choice izia agrees to collaborate with
the activists and they give her a ship
to insert in silas's computer the next
morning it's revealed that Moretti
frequently suffers from PTSD but he
keeps his struggles from PM Nadia he
slowly becomes consumed with hatred for
the unemployed and to make matters worse
Nadia unwittingly confides in him that a
solidarity worker killed his employer
the other day and that she stopped the
media from reporting it to maintain
public order meanwhile Hans learns that
face hasn't drank water in two days as
Ethan has refused to give her clean
drinking water Disturbed and enraged he
confronts Ethan but the latter refuses
to budge unable to see her in this state
Hans reluctantly kills her and puts her
out of her misery why didn't he just
give her water the same day Reuben
appears for a grueling interview and as
part of it he is given the task of
firing his former colleague meanwhile
Izzie begins to get better at thesis job
and during the lunch break she heads to
silas's office but on her way there she
encounters the aquaville CEO Bartholome
the sadistic man cunningly invites her
to his office and then takes advantage
of her in exchange for promoting Reuben
later a group of solidarity workers run
away from their homes and gather at a
place to play football this alarms the
town residents as they are extreme
Workaholics who don't understand the
concept of recreation afraid of another
controversy PM Nadia sends alarkum and
Minister Moretti to speak with the
workers the latter runs away due to his
PTSD but fortunately larka manages to
send the workers back to their employers
on the other hand Noah again hangs out
with Valley and the two sneak into the
town via a secret tunnel Unfortunately
they are soon spotted by the police and
Noah wanders deeper into the town while
Valley runs back to the Zone fearing for
his life Noah heads to Ruben's house as
his mother had once disclosed to the
directions to there after work Reuben
and izia also head back home and the
latter reveals how the CEO took
advantage of her surprisingly Reuben
isn't faced as it is common in the town
for wives to sacrifice their dignity for
their husbands this upsetsia and she
accuses him of only caring about his
promotion when they reach home they are
stunned to find Noah inside at this
point the town has also been put on high
alert because of the infiltration izia
is scared for her son's safety so Reuben
offers to drive him to the wall on their
way there he apologizes to izia for
everything and reveals that he
desperately wants the promotion so that
he can afford to send his daughter to
Phoenix Academy shortly after when the
mother-son Duo returned home Noah
accuses izia of selling out at work
puzzled and enraged she slaps his ass
and demands to know why he's been acting
out lately Noah finally confronts her
about the lie and she explains
everything about how Ethan abandoned
them because of his activism the next
day Moretti suddenly appears on TV where
he goes on a hateful rant against
unemployed people and warns that an
invasion is imminent much to Nadia's
dismay despite this she refuses to give
up on her husband and puts him under a
24 7 watch she then seeks advice from
her father Mr pasarun who is revealed to
be a former French prime minister the
wall was actually built during his
tenure Nadia mentions that she feels the
wall was a mistake but her father
asserts that it was the only solution
later she asks larkham to bring a video
proof of how the program has changed his
life Nadia plans to release the video
before the arrival of the president of
the World Bank at aquaville Ruben's
competitor for the managerial position
finds out about izzia's truth and starts
blackmailing Reuben the latter requests
her keep her mouth shut but she just
won't listen so with no other way out
Reuben kills her he then contacts his
father and the two get rid of the body
that evening Reuben reveals everything
to isia and breaks into tears after
realizing what a monster he has become
is he a feel sorry for him and tries
comforting him one thing leads to
another and they end up making love at
the Zone Saul the leader of the
activists finally arrives and shows
himself in a shocking turn of events he
is revealed to be none other than Noah's
teacher Robinson he along with with his
Rebels are planning to invade the town
but for that to happen they are counting
on izia to steal the data from aquaville
the following day the president of the
World Bank finally comes for a visit and
PM Nadia introduces him to larkham later
she holds a private meeting with the
president and requests him to release
the funds as they are in desperate need
of them however the president tells her
that the International Community is
apprehensive about supporting her
government because she still hasn't
removed Moretti who incited violence
against the unemployed from her cabinet
as a result PM Nadia finally decides to
remove her husband Moretti from the
cabinet she also disavows all of his
hateful comments towards the unemployed
this finally pleases the World Bank
president and he releases the funds to
Nadia's government Moretti is deeply
hurt and he later admits to Nadia that
the rebels forced him into revealing
State Secrets it turns out that
aquaville is purposely polluting Zone's
water with the government's blessing for
profit and power Nadia panics but she
quickly comes up with a solution back in
aquaville Reuben appears for his final
interview before he is selected for the
managerial opposition at first he States
his strengths but then he goes
completely off topic and Frames his
final competitor for the murder of
Peterson he also presents bogus evidence
doctored by Silas to back his claim
which results in the competitor's
disqualification meanwhile Noah and
Valley show up at the secret hideout of
the activists and to demand to meet
Ethan as expected no one has heard of
that name before and they ask the
teenagers to go away Noah and Valley
oblige but on their way out they get
away from the guard and manage to sneak
inside the building they then eavesdrop
on the conversation of the activists and
Noah learns that his teacher Robinson is
the leader of the group in the next
scene izia returns for work at aquaville
and finally manages to enter silas's
office she successfully extracts the
data in her chip but before she can
leave with it Silas arrives and catches
her red-handed he attacks her but she
somehow manages to escape along with the
chip wasting no time Silas alerts his
son about izia's treachery and Reuben
catches her before she leaves the
building he slaps her and in the process
she drops the chip izia then comes clean
that she was forced by the activists to
collaborate later Silas advises his son
to kill izia but Reuben refuses and
instead decides to let her go for all
that she has done for him and his
daughter he even drives her to the wall
but before izia can cross over to the
Zone she is caught by silas's man she is
interrogated and Silas finally learns
that she was supposed to steal data from
his computer and hand it over to someone
Silas is enraged by the Revelation but
nonetheless he also takes it as the
perfect opportunity to capture the
activists he sends isia as bait to a
rendezvous spot and when Nadia's head of
security Gene shows up his men capture
her meanwhile larcom is given a chance
to permanently move to the town he
excitedly asks his wife to come with her
but she turns him down this leads to an
argument and larkham decides to move to
the town by himself a few hours later he
arrives at his new home where he is
ordered to meet Moretti shockingly he
finds the former Minister floating in
the pool dead Justice larkham is trying
to make sense of the situation the prime
minister's daughter Zoe appears and
shoots him dead geez later Nadia finds
out about the pamphlets and decides to
go through with the last stage of her
plan she appears before the media and
announces the murder of her husband
Monroe Moretti she frames the larcom for
the murder and explains that he was shot
dead while trying to escape Nadia then
goes on a rant against the zoners
claiming that their hatred towards the
unemployed people is reaching dangerous
levels saying this she declares the
suspension of the solidarity work
program she also announces a mass raid
on the zone to catch the activists
amidst all of this Silas briefs
aquaville CEO Bartholome about the
unfortunate events on his orders Gene is
burned and tortured before being locked
up with izia Silas and Bartholome then
meet Nadia and reveal that her head of
security Gene Mars is actually working
for the rebels later grateful to Silas
for stopping a major Scandal Bartholome
gives his son Reuben the promotion and
also gets little mael and admission into
the Phoenix Academy meanwhile Saul and
the rebels learn that izia and Jean have
been caught worried for their safety
Hans insists on rescuing the two but
Saul refuses saying he can't destroy the
activist Network by trying to rescue
them Noah and Valley overhear the
conversation and they are appalled to
learn that the rebels are just as bad as
the people they are opposing Noah then
vows to rescue his mother in the next
scene Silas informs Reuben about his
promotion and the latter excitedly goes
to aquaval to accept his new position
however there he finds the chip that
izia had dropped earlier he plays the
Chip And is taken aback to see the
overwhelming proof of aquaville
poisoning the drinking water for profit
and control appalled Reuben decides to
anonymously upload the information
online and defect from the town for good
he then picks up his daughter and rushes
to the wall to find izia the bombshell
revelation spreads like wildfire and
Saul and the activists Rejoice on the
other hand Silas orders his I.T team to
trace the person who leaked the
information PM Nadia also panics and
immediately comes before the media she
calls the whole leak a smear campaign
and warns that strict actions will be
taken against those responsible for it
elsewhere Reuben and mael cross over the
Zone through the secret passage where
they encountered Noah and Valley
preparing to enter the town the two
parties have a quick chat and when
Reuben learns that izia has been
arrested he asks Noah to take care of
mael while he goes to rescue izia a
while later the rebels finally launch an
invasion from multiple fronts and
Nadia's defense measures are easily
overwhelmed this is because many Town
residents have started opposing her and
many have already left their jobs Hans
and the others also enter the town to
finish the mission however Ethan Parts
ways with them and he goes to look for
izia Reuben also shows up at aquaville
looking for izia and Silas realizes that
his own son is behind the leak when the
two meet an enraged Reuben holds his dad
hostage and threatens him to reveal
izia's location unfortunately at the
same time the police discover that he is
behind the data leak and arrest him
Reuben is then locked up along with izia
nevertheless he is happy to be reunited
with her meanwhile the war intensifies
the wall come down and thousands of
zoners enter the town Nadia Zoe and
Bartholome starts smelling defeat and he
begins to worry them at the PM's
residence Zoe breaks into tears and
blames her mother for everything she
vows to join hands with the rebels and
testify against her before storming out
on the other hand the prison guards are
ordered to shoot all prisoners as one of
them shoots Reuben Ethan suddenly shows
up and neutralizes the guard he and his
men take izia and a wounded Reuben to
safety at the same time Soul reaches the
PM's residence and seemingly executes
her behind closed doors just then Zoe
arrives and offers to help him manage
the country three days pass by Reuben
recovers in the hospital and isia
reunites with her Noah the latter
finally meets his father Ethan but
realizes that after so many years apart
he is now just a stranger izia then
tells Reuben that she wants to choose
the third option and become his wife
much to Reuben's Joy Noah also accepts
the decision and he asks Valley to come
live with his family but Valley politely
declines and and parts ways with him at
a press conference Seoul finally
announces the end of the discriminatory
political system in the beginning of a
new equal and better life spoken like a
true politician later he speaks to
former PM Mr Pason and shockingly it's
revealed that Saul is actually his son
and Nadia's brother he had thrown Saul
out because of his political
indifferences in the final scene as Mr
pasaran is berating his son Nadia
suddenly appears and it turns out she
has also joined forces with Saul much to
the old man's astonishment subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching